ducati durch hat gehört ihr macht so
eine idee termin pharmacol um auf die
etwa herr matthias schön dass du wenn
man tatsächlich eine summer school und
sagen wir den letzten jahr zum ersten
mal gemacht
vielleicht erinnern sich einige von euch
nämlich auch videos dabei gemacht
unterlagen einfach menschen aus aller
welt ein mit uns deutsch zu lernen aber
das was wir machen ist eben nicht so
eine sprachschule wie man das sonst
macht das man in dem klassenraum sitzt
und vokabeln und grammatik pauken
sondern die vokabeln und grammatik
lernen wir bei aktivitäten
denn wenn man aktiv hält macht merkt man
sich viel mehr felder pflügen ball
vielleicht kann ich auch mal deutsch
lernen endlich das wäre auch eine
geschichte aus fläche kann einfach
vorbeikommen denn das sind wir machen
macht auch noch spaß ohne dass man
deutschland siegen zum beispiel
wir machen solche schnitzeljagd in der
stadt man muss mit fremden menschen auf
der straße sprechen dafür saugen sie
gehen einkaufen wie kochen typisch
deutsche gerichte wir schauen deutsche
filme wir machen ausleger jetzt waren
wir zb im winter wandel an der ostsee
und im sommer waren den dresden und all
das machen wir und haben dabei immer so
kleine übungen ein großer und letztes
jahr werden leute dabei aus indien aus
den usa aus indonesien die durch alle
nach deutschland gekommen und gern
deutsch gelernt und jetzt gehts nicht
los ihr könnt euch jetzt registrieren
die registrierung für unsere
sommerschule im jahr 2017 sind nämlich
jetzt geöffnet wir haben noch ein paar
plätze frei ein paar leute handtaschen
registriert und das ganze könnt ihr hier
unten machen wir haben ein formular und
dann bekommt ihr eine nachricht von
alles gleich antworten die organisiert
das ganze wie ein bisschen und dann
hoffen wir dass wir uns im sommer in
berlin sehen alle informationen findet
ihr unten mit einem link zu allen infos
und im registrierungsformular
vermeintlicher vorjahr
[Musik]
[Applaus]